Bernard 3 nous accompagne donc sur ce
début d'édition du 78 il est question du
lycée hôtelier de guillancour dont vous
êtes le proviseur l'établissement qui
fait po neu mi avril c'est un peu une
date charnière pour vous la première
phase de travaux qui s'achève la seconde
qui va débouter vous en êtes où
justement sur cette immense chantier de
de rénovation on est bien loin d'un
simple coup de pinture exactement oui
alors c'est un peu une période de
transition puisque effectivement comme
le dire deux entreprises se succèdent
l'une vient d'achever les travaux
préparatoires à savoir le
essentiellement le désamiantages hein
qui aura duré une année je dire ce qui a
duré le plus longtemps effectivement ce
sont les démarches administratives lié à
la passation d'un marché puisqueil
s'agit d'un marché public et environ 3 à
4 mois de travaux pour désamienter le
bâtiment alors on voit à quoi va
ressembler ce bâtiment justement mais ce
sera dans quelques mois voir quelques
années puisque la livraison définitive
du bâtiment c'est mi2000
vous l'avez dit il a fallu désamionter
aussi là on voit la fin du du chantier
c'était il y a il y a quelques jours à
saint-quenttin en nieline à Guill en
cours laamante ça a été la mauvaise
surprise de ce début des travaux
exactement on s'en serait bien passé et
puis les entreprises enfin le la
maîtrise d'ouvrage la région
Île-de-France qui finance les travaux et
les entreprises qui ont été chargées du
travail ont bien réagi et fait en sorte
que le bâtiment soit entièrement
assaaini avant les travaux de rénovation
proprement dites c'est vrai que c'est
important à à fois en terme de délais
supplémentairire et également en terme
de surcût mais je pense que c'était une
phase obligatoire avant d'envisager la
rénovation de ce lycée le surcout sera
de combien on est sur une enveloppe de
quelques 50 millions d'euros ça 50
millions c'est l'enveloppe de rénovation
global auquel il faut ajouter je pense
entre 5 et 10 millions de travaux
supplémentaires en ce qui concerne le
désamiantage et l'assaainissement total
des des des bâtiments le désamientage
est derrière vous une nouvelle
entreprise est en train de s'installer
actuellement quels sont les travaux qui
vont vont être mené
actuellement on est encore dans une
phase de préparation puisque le la
rénovation prévoit de garder toute la
structure porteuse du bâtiment mais il y
a quand même quelques modifications
structurelles et on va commencer par
démolir un certain nombre de de
bâtiments qui seront reconstruit par la
suite avec des des formes et des
aménagements différents donc on commence
par démolir ce sont des conditions
difficiles pour les élèves actuellement
les quelques 700 élèves que vous
accueillez tout à fait alors les élèves
ne sont bien sûr pas sur le chantier
hein puisquil y a une séparation
physique entre chantier et établissement
en fonctionnement donc les élèves sont
on a répartie si vous voulez les
surfaces entre une partie est du
bâtiment qui est conservé en activité et
puis la surface perdue par les travaux
et bien nous avons des bâtiments
démontables 3000 m² qui ont été
construits quand même et qui permettent
d'assurer l'ensemble des cours hein dans
des conditions j'allais dire tout à fait
convenables hein pour le genre
d'activité d'un d'un lycée d'hôtellerie
de tourisme vous n'avez pas réduit
l'activité de l'établissement durant
cette période de travau toujours le même
nombre d'élèves alors on s'y est préparé
bien en amont jeallais dire ça fait 6
ans que je dirige ce lycée et quand je
suis arrivé et que cette mission m'a été
confiée d'amener le lycée dans sa
rénovation peu à peu on a modelé la
structure de façon à atteindre un un
régime de fonctionnement qui se
stabilise autour de 700 élèves hein de
façon à rendre possible l'ensemble des
cours hein dans les bâtiments provisoir
qui sont à notre disposition
actuellement le lycée date du début des
années 80 ces travaux étaient devenus
indispensabl ne serait-ce que pour
offrir des conditions de travail qui
soient à la hauteur même des autres
établissements qui proposent également
de se former à ces métiers d'hôtellerie
plus qu'à la hauteur on va les dépasser
et on espère bien effectivement que dans
2 ans nous sera livré un bâtiment tout à
fait à la fois fonctionnel bien équipé
aux normes à la fois en terme de
d'activité pédagogique mais aussi un
bâtiment qui sera aux normes
environnementales actuell l'enjeu est
véritablement de taille parce que
l'hôtellerie c'est un secteur qui est
très porteur malgré la crise c'est un
embauche encore toujours ça veut dire
que il y a beaucoup de concurrence entre
ces différents
établissements de plus en plus il est
vrai que le secteur est enorteur on a
effectivement des établissements qui se
lancent qui on est plutôt sur une une
évolution positive dans dans ce secteurl
le LCE hôtelier de 50 an Yveline est
pour l'instant un petit peu stabiliser
mais il se prépare effectivement à
revenir sur la la scène de la formation
professionnelle dans vous AZ une
ambition nationale sur cette sur la
formation globalement mais aussi au
niveau international le lycée
d'hôtellerie de 50 ans Yveline attire
des étudiants de toute l'Europe tout à
fait on est au niveau national un des
plus grands établissements je en terme
de proposition de de formation hein qui
intègre toutes les toutes les formations
de la restauration de l'hôtellerie et
aussi du tourisme qui est actuellement
en pleine rénovation au niveau de son
référentiel de formation et puis on
continue malgré les travaux à accueillir
des délégations européennes ou
internationales et à proposer à tous nos
étudiants la possibilité de faire des
période de formation en entreprise en
milieu professionnel en Europe et à
l'international les étudiants qui
s'inscrivent actuellement c'est la
période pour s'inscrire dans vos
établissements c'est la période
d'orientation avec les dispositifs que
l'on connaît maintenant d'affectation
postbac en particulier pour le postebac
ou à felnet pour les les affectations
post 3e puisqu'on recrute sur ces deux
plateau de recrutement bon c'est
toujours une période particulière pour
nous mais je pense que le lycée
d'hôellerie et de tourisme de
saintanttin Yveline conserve malgré
cette période de travaux une bonne
attractivité et on espère bien faire
encore en 2013 une bonne rentrée comme
on a pu le constater en 2012 parce que
les cours se poursuivent justement pour
ces étudiants qui se diraient le lycée
va être être en travaux c'est pas
forcément des conditions optimum pour
travailler vous leur diriez quoi écoutez
euh les conditions dans les tout ce qui
est plateau technique sont euh
excellentes hein puisque on a vraiment
là une construction remarquable hein où
on a pu développer des plateaux
techniques qui n'ont rien à envié à des
installations fixes là où on a un peu
perdu de surface évidemment c'est tout
ce qui concerne le la salle nous avions
euh des salles importantes en
restauration une salle de conférence
toutes ces équipements là pour l'instant
sont en travaux nous serons restitués
dans le courant de l'année 2015 donc on
aura rapidement un retour à des
meilleurs équipements une dernière
question le taux de réussite sur les
différents examens comment se porte
votre établissement ben écoutez il
seorte plutôt bien puisque on a des des
moyennes j'ai dire des pourcentages des
taux de réussite qui sont pour les plus
bas autour de 80 % et qui monte pour
certaines formations à 100 %. donc là
encore on peut dire que l'efficacité de
notre système n'est plus à démontrerin
et malgré les travaux on a aussi mais
aussi on a toujours des bons élèves le
résultat ce n'est pas que le lycée c'est
également l'engagement personnel des
élèves dans leur formation et c'est ce
que l'on souhaite avoir encore à la
rentrée 2013 merci Bernard 3 le lycée
hôtelier qui fait donc pot neuve le
chantier qui se poursuit hein vous le
verrez même si vous n'êtes pas étudiant
on ne peut pas manquer ces travaux
d'envergure à Guill en cours et nous
viendrons bien sûr vous rendre visite
d'ici la la liv raison complète de
l'ensemble du bâtiment ce sera mi 2016
pour on sera pas vous inviter on fera
une belle fête Merci à VOUS Bernard 3